o estilo estudo da alquimia buscava
criar pedra filosofal
era uma substância com propriedades
fantásticas capaz de mudar qualquer
metal em ouro
eles também queriam descobrir o elixir
da vida que traria saúde riqueza ea
imortalidade mas os alquimistas também
estavam interessados em descobrir a
relação do ser humano com cosmo e usar
esse conhecimento para elevar o espírito
humano a de alckmin era uma disciplina
espiritual e filosófica mas também usou
a química eu trabalho com metais além da
química ela também abrangeu a física à
geologia à biologia à medicina e até
mesmo a arte algum dos personagens mais
conhecidos mas foi mais famosos da
história da ciência estudaram e até
mesmo praticar alquimia entre eles
robert boyle e isaac newton
hoje trabalhando com nanociência e
nanotecnologia eu tenho que saber sobre
física química biologia ciências de
materiais e até mesmo sobre engenharia
talvez nós pesquisadores que trabalhamos
nesse meio tão interdisciplinar somos os
novos somos otimistas modernos mas ao
contrário dos antigos alquimistas a
gente não quer descobrir o elixir da
vida eterna
o que a gente quer saber o que a gente
quer entender é o que ocorre com essa
escala tão pequena escala nanométrica e
usar as propriedades desses materiais
para proporcionar uma vida melhor para
as pessoas como por exemplo detectar o
câncer precocemente
recentemente eu li que existem mais
casos de câncer todos os anos câncer de
pele todos os anos o que a incidência
combinada de câncer de mama próstata
pulmão e cólon uma dessas mas as mortes
por câncer de pele são muito baixas e um
dos motivos é que a gente pode ver o
câncer de pele a gente não se olha ea
gente pode ver qualquer lesão e pode ser
cancerosas ou pré cancerosa
o câncer de pele quando detectado
precocemente
o tratado é quase sempre curável mas
como é que a gente vai enxergar o que
está acontecendo dentro do nosso corpo
o método mais simples e mais barata que
seria acessível a todos e por um simples
exame de sangue
infelizmente todos os biomarcadores
utilizados hoje em clínica e exames de
sangue não são específicos para o tumor
em si
eles são usados para a seguir o
crescimento de tumores já em etapas
avançadas ou até mesmo para seguir o
tratamento do dado esse tumor
hoje o câncer é detectado quando algum
circo com algum sintoma já surgiu o
diagnóstico é realizado com o testes
muito invasivos como biópsias as opções
do índico cerca do tumor mas o que é um
biomarcador que eu tô falando aqui um
marcador é uma substância que pode nos
dar alguma informação sobre o estado
fisiológico do nosso corpo podem ser
proteínas por exemplo ea composição de
proteínas no sangue da gente não pode
nos dar informação de todos os órgãos e
tecidos através do mar não há uma rede
de artérias veias e capilares tumores e
outras doenças fatais secretam proteínas
a corrente sanguínea
mas quando o tumor está bem no início
começando a se desenvolver quando a
gente ainda não tem nenhum sintoma mas
que se tratado o tratamento é muito
eficaz ele secreta na corrente sanguínea
concentrações ultra baixas de proteína
mas além disso esse não é o único
problema o de exibir o marcador ele está
no caso do complexo que é o plasma
sanguíneo que contém mais de outras 10
mil proteínas em concentrações muito
mais altas
é aquela velha história de tentar
encontrar a agulha no palheiro mas nas
últimas nas últimas décadas da
tecnologia proporcionou uma grande
variedade de nanossensores são seleções
que têm uma escala nanométrica muito
pequenininha e provaram ser muito
sensíveis em alguns deles provaram
poderia detectar apenas uma molécula
infelizmente como a área sensor é tão
pequena a detecção de concentrações
ultra baixas de mil marcadores pode
levar dias
além disso eles apresentaram alguns
problemas como altas taxas de falar
os positivos falsos negativos e são
pouco reproduzíveis e por isso eles
estão ainda muito longe uma aplicação
real biomédica então atualmente não
existe nenhuma tecnologia com
sensibilidade e especificidade e
reprodutibilidade suficientes para
detectar mil marcadores que indicam o
início do desenvolvimento do tumor com
um simples exame de sangue mas
recentemente eu desenvolvi um sensor
muito sensível muito simples como
instrumentação muito básica e com grande
potencial para se transformar em uma
tecnologia que possa detectar tanto
câncer como outras doenças fatais com um
simples exame de sangue como os exames
de sangue que a gente faz todo ano
checape pra isso eu usei para
desenvolver sensores dizer um método que
a gente chama e saiu sanduíche mensais
sanduíche
a proteína que é o nosso e o marcador
nesse caso ele é detectado por dois
anticorpos cada de corpo ele reconhece
uma região diferente da proteína
então o que eu fiz no começo eu me
mobilizei o anticorpo na superfície do
meu sensor
em seguida todos os espaços vazios e
sensor eles foram bloqueados com uma
molécula para impedir que outras
proteínas aquele caldo complexo que é o
plasma sangüíneo se pega superfície do
sensor e assim evitamos o sistema dos
falsos positivos e falsos negativos em
seguida mergulhamos esse sensor na
mostra e capturamos um biomarcador mas
agora a gente tem uma área micro métrica
um micrômetro são meu nome' tros uma
área muito maior para a gente aumentar a
probabilidade do sensor capturar a
proteína e conseguimos capturar a
proteína em apenas uma hora depois desse
passo a gente passa o nosso sensor com
nosso biomarcador já capturado na
proteína na superfície do sensor por uma
solução que contém nanopartículas de
ouro e essas nanopartículas de ouro
também estão funcionalizadas com outro
anticorpo que é o nosso de corpo de
detecção como eu desenhei aqui em todo
seu desenho meu são uma forma de
trampolim
isso tem um sentido
eles são bem parecidos com trampolim
mesmos trampolim que a gente tem na
piscina mas eles são bem pequenininhos e
eles vibram a uma determinada freqüência
de ressonância mas quando algo se pega
sua superfície a freqüência de
ressonância dele muda de maneira
proporcional à massa da partícula
então é muito fácil que a gente faz é
bastante simples
a gente mede a freqüência de ressonância
do nosso sensor e depois do
reconhecimento da captura do biomarcador
e depois de passar o nosso sensor pela
solução que nanopartículas de ouro
assim podemos pesar a massa de
nanopartículas nosso trampolim em
relacionar com a quantidade de bianca
dores na mostra mas temos as
nanopartículas de ouro que tem uma uma
propriedade muito interessante quando
eliminamos nanopartículas de ouro com
diferentes longitudes de onda ou seja
com diferentes cores da luz a uma
determinada longitude de onda ela vai
vai ocorrer um fenômeno físico ela vai
absorver e dispersar a luz ou seja ela
vai brilhar nessa longitude de onda aqui
nesse espectro e iluminando partícula
que eu usei no meu sensor ea gente vê um
máximo do pico em mais ou menos 620 aqui
entre o amarelo eo vermelho que dá essa
cor laranja que a gente vê naquela
margem de dona partícula em cima
eu descobri outra coisa o nosso
trampolim
as duas superfícies do trampolim
funcionam como espelhos que aumentam a
sua refletividade em determinadas
longitude de onda então quando a gente
ilumina o nosso trampolim em alguma
atitude de onda algumas cores ele vai
brilhar mais
e esse efeito é observado o trampolim se
observamos essa outra parte aqui que é o
que suporta o trampolim esse efeito
insignificante o que acontece então
quando a nanopartícula está na
superfície do trampolim que acontece é
que o brilho dessa nanopartículas é
aumentado em pelo menos dez mil vezes
mas o outro foi o outro fenômeno que a
gente ouve é muito importante é muito
interessante observado
olhamos a detecção do ps há na parte do
suporte a gente vê algumas
nanopartículas mas parece que a gente
tem uma quantidade muito maior de nano
partículas na superfície do trampolim a
que está acontecendo o que eu fiz foi
pegar a minha mostra outro microscópio
eletrônico de varredura que o
microscópio que ajuda a gente enxergar
essas peças dessas partículas tão
pequenininhos e eu contei quantas
nanopartículas eu tinha no trampolim e
quantas nanopartículas eu tinha no
suporte que sustenta o trampolim é
impressionante mas tinha a mesma
densidade de nanopartículas e aí que tá
acontecendo contar pra vocês que está
acontecendo é que a luz refratada sofre
diversos rebotes na cavidade do do
trampolim e gerando uma uma cascata de
interações de reflexos da nanopartícula
também nessa qualidade
o que acontece é que a nanopartícula vai
produzir diversas imagens dela mesmo e
isso foi crucial para a gente conseguir
um limite de detecção tão baixo pra
desenvolver se e sensor eu usei como o
modelo dois marcadores já usados em
clínicas com esses mesmos programas que
não são específicos a um tumor né
eles foram dados somente como modelo
para desenvolver o sensor gente não
busca nenhuma melhora para a detecção
desses marcadores eu utilizei o céu eo
potencial do que a gente fez o e pegamos
a ips a ead
acionamos a um plasma comercial
realizamos diversas diversas diluições
até chegar à concentração de crp se á em
até 1 4 milhão de vezes mais diluído que
as proteínas do plasma na detecção pela
massa da nanopartícula chegamos a um
limite de detecção de atenas sem a
programas por mililitro do serra e de um
fotograma e por mililitro prosperou ps a
já na detecção que a gente usa o brilho
da nanopartícula chegamos a um limite de
detecção de 10 ator gramas por mililitro
do serra e sem a programas por mililitro
por ps a somos pelo menos um milhão de
vezes mais sensível do que as técnicas
utilizadas atualmente em clínica mas
será que eles são confiáveis a gente
pode confiar nesse esse sensor medimos
as taxas de erro tanto se usássemos
somente o sensor que mede a massa não
articula e um sensor que mede só o
brilho da nanopartícula a taxa de erro é
bastante baixa e eles provaram ser muito
reprodutíveis mas o mais impressionante
aconteceu quando fizemos um sinal
combinado das duas vezes seguidas duas
defecções e chegamos a impressionante
taxa de erro de apenas dois em cada dez
mil ensaios em 1959 richard freeman e
uma palestra que ele deu na caltech
intitulada há muito espaço na parte de
baixo ele mencionou a nanotecnologia sem
mesmo usar esse termo nanotecnologia
talvez a visão dele tão revolucionária
lançou essa corrida pela nanotecnologia
e 1980 na década de 80
esses dois pesquisadores da ibm
desenvolveram dois microscópios o
microscópio de corrente de tunelamento
também conhecido como stm e microscópio
de força atômica cfm que proporcionou a
nanotecnologia que a gente conhece hoje
mas o caminho não foi tão fácil
quando eles tentaram apresentar para a
comunidade científica ou microscópio de
corrente de tunelamento ele não foi
muito bem aceito e o trabalho deles foi
legado para a publicação
mas em 1986 eles ganharam o prêmio nobel
de física pela descoberta do stm
talvez eles sejam os culpados não está
aqui hoje contando pra vocês desse
sensor que desenvolvi e que eu espero
que no futuro próximo a gente encontra
um laboratório de pesquisa para
descoberta de biomarcadores e hospitais
e clínicas para detecção de câncer e
outras doenças totais com simples exame
de sangue mas como eu falei no início eu
não quero descobrir a fórmula da vida
eterna mas eu quero sim poder ajudar
milhões de a salvar milhões de vida
todos os anos
obrigada